على هزيمة موسكو برغم الدعم
الغربي المهول. فهل تأتي الهزيمة
الروسية على ايدي ابناء بوتين هي
حرب داخل حرب. وبينما داخ العالم
ذهابا وايابا لاجل الوساطة في
الحرب الاوكرانية. يبدو انه لم
يعد للصلح مكان بين القادة الروس
فقد استعرت الخلافات لتصبح الحرب
علنا بينهم. فالى اين المصير عن
ومناوشات فاغنر ووزارة الدفاع
الروسية نتحدث وللقصة بقية.
مقاتلات امريكية تقصف الاف من
الجنود الروس وتردي منهم مئات من
القتلى والجرحى. بينما الجيش
الروسي يشاهد بلا ردة فعل. كان
هذا المشهد الذي وقع قبل سنوات
في سوريا دليلا مبكرا على العداء
بين فاغنر والجيش الروسي. ومن
هناك كانت البداية لنداعب عقارب
الزمن قليلا. حيث كانت في فبراير
عام الفين وثمانية عشر. والتي
نشرت عنها الكثير من المواقع
الاخبارية والعالمية وعلى رأسها
شبكة البي بي سي. وكما نتصفح
امامكم المصدر فها هو يذكر
الحادثة بتفاصيلها. فمن منكم سمع
او رأى ان الجيش الروسي يترك
افراده خلفه او انه يكون شاهدا
على مقتلهم دون ان يحرك ساكنا.
انه مشهد مروع جعل مؤسس مجموعة
والملقب بطباخ بوتين يعيد
حساباته مرة اخرى. يدخل الحلبة
الاوكرانية عندما بدأت موسكو
عملياتها العسكرية ضد كياف كانت
الامور ضبابية. وبعد ان مرت ثلاث
اسابيع منذ اندلاع المعارك وفشل
القوات الروسية في الاستيلاء على
كياف. وخرجت العملية العسكرية
الخاصة عن الخطة. بعد فترة وجيزة
لجأ الجيش الروسي الى مجموعة
لتدخل وحدة القادمة من افريقيا
المعركة في مقاطعة لوهانسك بشرق
اوكرانيا كون المجموعة ذات خبرة
عميقة في قتال الشوارع وحرب
العصابات لتحقق فاغنر سلسلة من
عمليات التقدم الكبير. هذا ليس
بتقرير من عندنا بل هو حديث قائد
فاجنار بنفسه. لكن بريجوجان اضاف
انه حتى مع قيام فاغنر بتوسيع
التجنيد بشكل كبير. وخفض
المعايير. فان القتال الطاحن
سرعان ما استنفذ المتطوعين. فكر
بريجوجان قليلا ووجد الحل
بالاستفادة من الاعداد المهولة
للمدانين في السجون. في روسيا
وتجنيد المجرمين العنيفين بوعدهم
بالعفو. وهو شيء لا يستطيع
تحقيقه سوى بوتين. اذا بقوا على
قيد الحياة لمدة ستة اشهر في
اوكرانيا. وبالفعل حققوا التقدم
الوحيد لموسكو. منذ نحو عام ونصف
حيث انتصروا في باخموت بعد معركة
دامت شهورا ووصفت بمفرمة اللحم.
لكن قبل ان ينتصر فاغنر في
باخموت. هدد بريجوجن اكثر من مرة
بالانسحاب وهذه المرة ليس بسبب
نقص الجنود بل بسبب نقص العتاد.
انه يطلب الذخيرة لا غير. لكن
القيادة في موسكو لا تعيره
اهتماما حتى زاد من حدة
تهديداته. لتروي وزارة الدفاع
الروسية بعضا من عطشه للذخيرة
بدفعة بل بها بريجوجان. ريق
مجموعته اللاهثة. فانتصر في
باخموت بعد اكثر من عام على
المعارك هناك. سلمها فورا
للقيادة الروسية ليبحث عن جبهة
جديدة. لكن مهلا ماذا عن الذخيرة
ايها الطباخ؟ ويا لهذا الوابل من
الشتائم التي تلقتها القيادات
العسكرية الروسية. انتم كريهة
الرائحة ماذا تفعلون جالسين؟
انهضوا من مكاتبكم للدفاع عن هذا
البلد. لماذا تسمحون لهذه
الطائرة بدون طيار بضرب موسكو؟
نعم. نحن امام كلمات بسيطة من
طباخ بوتين اللاذع لقيادة الجيش
الروسي. بريغوشن اتهم وزير
الدفاع سيرجي شويغو صراحة
بالتغاضي عن فعل اي شيء لصد
التهديدات. فالعالم كله يعلم
خلافهما ولم يعد هناك ما يخفيه.
وقبل ذلك كان بريجوجان قد زعم
انه حذر مرارا وتكرارا من
تهديدات مماثلة، الا ان
المسؤولين لم يفعلوا شيئا لمنعه
لينتفض بريجوجان غضبا ويعلن
استعداده لحماية الاراضي الروسية
التي لم تستطع روسيا ان تحميها
كما وصف. لكن بريجوجان طلب
الذخيرة فقط. فبغيرها لن يقاتل.
ايضا طلب اخر ولكنه غريب ومضحك
هذه المرة. حيث قال انه يجب
ارسال مائتين من الجنرالات الروس
البالغ عددهم عشرة الاف الى
اوكرانيا. لماذا يا بريغوجين?
اجاب. لكي يجرب الركض. وهم
يرتدون الدروع الواقية على
الخطوط الامامية. وكانه لم يعد
للصلح مكان. فقد الخلافات بل
الحرب بين رئيس مجموعة فاجنر
العسكرية الروسية ووزارة الدفاع
علنا ولاول مرة بهذا الشكل
العنيد. عندها ايقنا ان هذه
المعارك والمناوشات الروسية
اصبحت حربا روسية بين القيادات
بداخل الحرب الاوكرانية.
فبريغوشان اصبح مترصدا لكل افعال
وزير الدفاع الروسي. وبعد اعلان
الوزارة قتل الف وخمسمائة جندي
في يوم واحد. قال بريجوجان ساخرا
انها واذا جمعنا كل الارقام التي
قدمتها الوزارة سنكون قد دمرنا
كوكب الارض برمته خمس مرات.
بريجو جيل لا يكتفي بنفي
التقارير والبيانات الروسية بل
يؤكد الاخبار الاوكرانية. وها هو
يؤكد استعادة قوات كييف اجزاء من
باخمارك واصفا الامر بانه عار
على روسيا. الخلافات طفت على
السطح ويبدو ان لا عودة على هذا
الخصام. وطباخ بوتين اصبح يدافع
عن اوكرانيا بنفيه لبعض العمليات
الروسية. مما يدافع الاوكران
انفسهم. وهنا بريجوجان يكرم
جنديا امريكيا بوضع العالم على
جثته وارساله الى امريكا. وهنا
يظهر طريق واحد بعد كل هذه
التوترات هو طريق الصراع
الداخلي. فاين هو بوتين من كل
هذا. بوتين في حيرة. اقرب الرجال
الى بوتين هم قادته. الذين
يعيشون صراعا غير مسبوق قد ينتج
عنه شرخ في السلطات الروسية.
وهذا ما بريجوجان. بل انه يزيد
على ذلك ان روسيا قد تواجه ثورة
مماثلة لتلك التي حدثت عام الف
وتسعمائة وسبعة عشر. وتخسر
الصراع في اوكرانيا ما لم تكن
النخبة جادة في خوض الحرب.
بريجوجان طرح المشكلة ويأتي
بالحل. قائلا لبوتين انه يجب
استبدال وزير الدفاع شويغو
بالعقيد ميخائيل. بينما يجب
استبدال رئيس الاركان العامة.
فاليري جيرا سيمو بسيرج الملقب
وختم حديثه بقوله انا احب وطني
الام انا اخدم بوتين يجب الحكم
على شويغو وسنواصل القتال واضاف
واصفا كبار رجال الجيش في بوتين
بانهم وسامحون على اللفظ فقد قال
انهم وسيلقون مصيرهم. اعداء
بريجوجن لا يردون على تصريحات
لكنهم لا يدعمونه بالاسلحة
والذخيرة ايضا. ليوجه هو وقواته
مصيرهم على ارض المعارك. ام
بوتين فهو في حيرة من امره. ان
يمضي بنصائح طباخه المقرب. ام
يستمع لوزير دفاعه ورئيس اركانه.
وهنا لم تنتهي الحكاية. وما دام
بريجوجن حي. فلن تتوقف انتقاداته
اللاذعة. بوتين لا يجهل كل ما
يحدث لكنه يعي تماما ان الجيش
خلال اوقات الحرب يميل الى كسب
مزيد من السلطة داخل الدولة.
ويعلم انه كلما استمرت الحرب
تزايدت هذه السلطة. وزادت صعوبة
ممارسة سيطرته لذا فهو يكبح جماح
جنرالاته بترك طباخه بريغوشن
يتحرك كما يحلو له ويقول ما
يريد. وطالما ان ذلك يجعل الامور
تظل محكمة في يد بوتين. فلا ضير
من مناوشات بعض القادة. الزعيم
الروسي لن يفرط بمجموعة فاغنر
التي اصبحت ذراعا لروسيا ليس في
اوكرانيا فقط بل في العالم
الخارجي. فقد اسست فاغنر لروسيا
امبراطورية في افريقيا بارخص
التكاليف. وهناك سبب اخر لصمت
بوتين تصريحات يافجيني وهذا
السبب قاله يافجيني حديثا بان
قواتنا لا تكفي للاطاحة ببوتين.
والرئيس الروسي يعي ذلك جيدا. في
روسيا يبدو ان كل شيء متوقف على
سير المعارك على الاراضي
الاوكرانية. فانحصار المعارك
وتمددها شيء. وخذلان القيادة
الروسية لمجموعة فاغنر شيء اخر.
لكن التراجع الروسي في اوكرانيا
قد لا ياتي بفعل القوات
الاوكرانية بل بسبب مناوشات
القادة الروس. هل يسمح بوتين
بذلك؟